katerstimmung auf mallorca die lokale am
ballermann müssen schließen die behörden
greifen endlich durch hunderte meist
deutsche touristen machen party ohne
rücksicht die spanier sind sauer und
auch bei uns wächst die besorgnis jens
spahn fürchtet wir müssen sehr aufpassen
dass der ballermann nicht ein zweites
spiel wird müssen jetzt alle rückkehrer
getestet werden und droht uns die
gefürchtete zweite welle weil masken
muffel im partyrausch wann für spanien
könnte der schuss nach hinten losgehen
wer bucht jetzt noch ballermann ohne
ballermann
tja da fangen uns natürlich hat die
spanische regierung da vielleicht etwas
voreilig alles wieder geöffnet und etwas
voreilig vorgeprescht meiner mama odie
hahn ja ich will die frage ja schon so
ein bisschen kritisch dem 1
ja ich finde die vorher kritisch denn
die spanier waren wirklich eisern also
auch was den lockeren angehen mit einer
großen disziplin und im grunde genommen
sind sie touristen unter anderem aus
deutschland geht das jetzt wieder
infrage stellen deswegen sich die
schuldfrage eigentlich gar nicht
gesprochen
wir wollen eure einen hammer oder macht
deutsche touristen benehmen sie angela
wanderleben konnte dass jemand behalten
doch lieber aber ich finde schon um auf
seine frage zurückzukommen
natürlich muss er jetzt gehandelt werden
und es tut mir wahnsinnig leid für die
gastronomen die jetzt gerade wieder
aufmachen dürften die jetzt auf all
ihren vorräten und in ihren mitarbeitern
sitzen und gleich wieder schließen
dürfen aber natürlich müssen wir da auch
konsequent sein und muss einfach klar
sein urlaub bedeutet keine
narrenfreiheit ferien ok feiern eben
nicht okay das geht in zeiten von corona
nicht egal wo egal wohin fährt immer mit
dem nun ab wie sieht es bei dir aus also
in meinem selbstverständnis finde ich
sollte man auf jeden fall wenn man in
den urlaub fährt man zurückkommt auch im
test machen ja dass das ist einfach so
und das sollte man so sehen
aber grundsätzlich kann ich auch alle
verstehen die auch urlaub machen wollten
und die daneben wegfahren wollen nur
dann bitteschön mit
verantwortungsbewusstsein
eben nicht ich mache jetzt party und
alles andere ist mir egal und dass das
ist etwas was man kritisieren muss aber
ich muss ein bisschen widersprechende
sind weil das ist ja so am ballermann
ist ja jetzt auch nicht überraschend
dass er das 1 234 50 bier getrunken
zwischendurch und mit alkohol fallen die
hemmungen das ist ganz klar und man
denkt man ist irgendwie nicht mehr das
nicht mehr relevante man macht so ein
bisschen so sein ding das ist ja jetzt
nicht wirklich wie du auch schon sagt
das nicht wirklich überraschend was ich
nicht verstehe ist ja schön und gut wenn
man das auf macht aber dann baut doch
etwas oder oder achtet darauf dass
vielleicht ein paar aufpasser da stehen
dass man irgendjemand hatte denn ich
dann erst dann auch zwischendurch mal
seit hallo stoppt so nicht immer so wie
man dabei das was ist denn zum beispiel
mit der selbstverantwortung also auch
der urlauber und ich sage mal gerade vor
dem hintergrund von ischgl wenn menschen
oder auch die urlauber nicht verstanden
haben dass dieser party urlaub einfach
eine ganz schlechte idee ist auch im
sinne der solidarität dass ich mit
meinem verhalten natürlich auch anderen
der gefahr aussetze
dann finde ich es immer noch falsch und
ich meine die tatsache ist natürlich
jetzt wurden die leben ja auch
geschlossen was passiert jetzt mit den
menschen die dort sind die zurückkehren
ich finde auch dass sie sich testen
lassen müssen denn die verschiedenen
verschwinden ja nicht irgendwo sondern
die gehen dann wieder in die
kindergärten in die schulen an die
arbeitsstätte also ich glaube das ist ja
auch nicht ich finde man muss einmal ein
bisschen weiter nach hinten gehen weil
wenn man die grenzen nicht aufgemacht
hätte wenn man in deutschland macht man
halt die nachtclubs nicht aus dem genau
aus dem grund nämlich und wenn man aber
schon sagt maja der ballermann lebt nun
man davon das kann ich ja irgendwo auch
nachvollziehen da muss man da auch
dementsprechend vorbeugen und das meiner
meinung nach hat das komplett gefehlt ja
und dass es nicht geklappt hat hat er
jetzt auch zur folge letztlich das
sozusagen die leben geschlossen wurden
sind aber noch mal ich möchte noch mal
sagen es war eine eiserne disziplin an
die sich knallhart vorher geworden ist
das haben die spanier besser hinbekommen
als viele andere länder weltweit und
jetzt dafür bestraft zu werden ist ja
auch verkehrt dann die leben ja davon
aber dazu gehört natürlich auch ein
verantwortungsbewusstes handeln und eine
clubszene jetzt zuzulassen in diesen
zeiten ist natürlich genauso
unverantwortlich
das problem ist natürlich auch dass es
erst mal nur bei ermahnungen blieb eine
abmahnung ist ja immer das passiert
natürlich nicht so dass ich meinen
kindern ja ich bin dann sage ich ziehe
bis drei die wissen genau bei drei
patienten
genauso ratlos war wieder vor auch das
heißt natürlich ist muss mit bußgeldern
belegt werden es muss mehr darauf
geachtet werden es müssen finde ich auch
teilweise geschäfte geschlossen werden
mit tut mir wahnsinnig leid für die die
eben gerade aufgemacht werden und dann
wird eine ganze schinkenstraße zu
gemacht wo man vielleicht sagen könnte
schaut wir finden ein kompromiss ein
bier wird getrunken im achten auf die
gästezahl das sind natürlich jetzt
konsequenzen die dort wieder eine ganze
branche brach lägen also ich glaube zum
beispiel und das mir persönlich fehlen
so ein bisschen die ansprachen von frau
merkel ich hätte es schön gefunden wenn
frau merkel zum beispiel gesagt hätte so
bald geht es hier mit der urlaubszeit
los denkt daran liebe mitbürger
mitbürgerinnen oder wie auch immer
corona fährt weg wir sind noch aufpassen
da uns noch mal so einen mitgegeben hat
das tat in der korona zeit in dem locker
und so wahnsinnig gut woran denkst du
wenn du an mallorca denkst du wenn du
die bilder sie ist geht es dir auch so
dass hier ein bisschen halt fehlt
vielleicht oder dass es den vielleicht
fehlt was er gesagt du warst ja nicht da
oder nee ich war nicht da ich würde auch
nicht bin ja auch heute mit dem auto
hierher gefahren
aber wenn du sagst du hättest das von
frau merkel gewünscht
ich sage mir es muss doch jedem klar
sein welche konsequenz das hat und da
brauche ich keine mutter oder keine frau
merkel die mir sagt wenn ich die denn
wenn ich in so ein ballungszentrum
fahrer und so viele menschen aufeinander
treffen und ich halte den abstand nicht
hat das zur konsequenz dass ich mich
aller wahrscheinlichkeit anstecke und
dann kann es doch nur in meinem sinne
sein wenn ich sorgsam bin wenn ich
fürsorglich bin und weiß ich hatte
eltern zu hause die 70 sind und die ja
also ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen
dass die menschen die in den in den
urlaub fahren dann auch nicht selber
darauf achten dass man den abstand hält
dass man auch mit zwei drei bier
kurzweilig spaß hat aber dennoch darauf
zu achten dass ich verantwortungsbewusst
damit umgehen
naja wenn alle so denken wir da hätten
wir das problem natürlich nicht nur
deswegen dass wenn ich natürlich auch
sehr schade wir haben alle auf die
ansprache von der kanzlerin warten
würden um ihr handeln zu unterfranken
ist auch gut dass das verstehe ich auch
aber mir hat sie gefehlt
frau merkel gefehlt muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen jetzt kurz vor dem vor dem
wo anfangen jetzt ist natürlich die
freiheit das hat mir gerade schon
angesprochen testen lassen wäre
natürlich schön wenn ich habe das gefühl
es gibt irgendwie kaum tests also es
nicht möglich einen test zu machen so
richtig und ich fände es schön wenn es
normal wäre oder auch einfach wäre und
und auch vor allem auch günstiger wäre
sich testen zu lassen
trotzdem ist natürlich die frage soll
man sich jetzt hessen lassen soll jeder
der jetzt aus mallorca kommt erstmal
quarantäne wie soll man das jetzt hier
hand haben ja so oder so also wenn ich
den test nicht machen kann dann würde
ich also ich in meinem verständnis erst
mal zu hause bleiben und warten wenn ich
den test nicht sofort machen kann du
hast aber recht also es relativ
schwierig ist ein test zu kommen ich
kann das nur aus meinem freundeskreis
berichten mit den kindern die kriegen
den test auch nicht sofort und also von
daher tipps diese option zu sagen dann
bleibe ich eben zwei wochen in
quarantäne
ja das tut natürlich sehr viel mehr weh
als der test alle wünschen sich
natürlich tests für zuhause konterfeit
nach mallorca dann sündige ich deutlich
setzt wieder hin feier und so weiter ich
mach danach den test wird schon gut
gehen und dann wer soll das bezahlen
wird zeit den testern die urlauber oder
ist soll das dann auch der staat für
einen regeln so ist ja dann auch auf die
forderung ja dann müsst ihr halt auf uns
alle achten
und natürlich weil die wenigsten einfach
die konsequenz ziehen zu sagen ich passe
jetzt mal auf ich gehe zwei wochen
wirklich in quarantäne und quarantäne
bedeutet ja nicht ich bleibe viel zu
hause sondern mein bett wirklich zu
hause und die verantwortung übernimmt
wahrscheinlich keiner träumen ihre vor
allem die die wirklich da dann feiern ob
die das verantwortungsgefühl zu haben
ich gehe in quarantäne es ja eher das
gegenteil dass diejenigen bestraft
werden die sowieso verantwortungsbewusst
sind die wahrscheinlich nicht den
partyurlaub machen sondern in den
ruhigen ecken mallorcas sehen sind und
jetzt dann auch mit in quarantäne
müssten derzeit wieder dieses beispiel
zeigt wieder dass alle dafür bestraft
werden für ein fahrzeug das verhalten
von ein paar aber dass kunden frage
teste ja oder nein
ja natürlich aber aus eigener kasse ja
ja ja ja ja aber als kurzes aber das
wird ja nicht morgen zu ende sein also
es ist ja so dass wir sowieso lösungen
brauchen wir die wir in den nächsten
möglicherweise 123 jahren
damit umgehen also es ist ja nicht damit
getan jetzt zu sagen ja jetzt war das
einmal das würde uns ja noch weiter
begleiten